Okay. Welcome to Unit 5 Office Hours. We had a lot of great questions in the forums.
Before we get into those, I think you wanted to mention something about memcache that you--
eah. >>--you were worried you weren't too clear on.
Sure. Yeah. Somebody asked me a question I received this morning that made me think.
There's a 10-second piece of advice I can give you that'll make the homework or Unit 6
actually a lot easier, which you should be working on right about now.
We're using memcache basically to store strings and integers.
In your code you can say something like memcache.set.
I realized as I was writing this stuff I'm trying not to speak while I'm writing so they can edit it.
But anyway, you can say memcache.set and then you give it a key.
It'll just be a string. It's always a string. That's the memcache protocol.
And in the memcache protocol it says the value has to be a string as well.
However, we're using this library--this Python memcache library that Google provides
and most Python memcache libraries have the same behavior which is
you can put just about anything as the value.
The value can be another string. It can also be just an integer.
Or it can even be a Python data structure.
You can give it a little dictionary.
What might be useful in the homework you'll find
would be a tuple with maybe a time stamp and another string.
Something like that perhaps. We'll see.
But you can store this value and then when you get the value back out of memcache
the library will take the encoded string and convert it back into your Python data structure.
So as long as there are simple things in here and by simple things I basically mean lists, dictionaries,
primitive data types, you can get away with some objects but they have to be picklable.
That's the Python library they're using called "pickle," which converts a Python object into a string.
Most simple objects will work as well.
Everything we do in this class should be memcacheable without any trouble.
Data for entities can be memcached with no trouble, so you can actually store whatever you like.
So that should help with the homework.